YUFENG GUO: As machine
learning has taken off
in the last few years,
the increased demand
for specialized computing
resources for training
and predictions has led to
the development of Tensor
Processing Units, or TPUs.
But where do they come from and
how do they work on the inside?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[SPACESHIP NOISES]
Welcome to "AI
Adventures," where
we explore the art, science,
and tools of machine learning.
My name is Yufeng Guo,
and on this episode,
we're going to begin
a two-part adventure
into the world of
high-performance computing
at Google.
In the first episode, we'll
look at the original TPU,
its design, and
how it came to be
used in everything from Google
Photos to Google Translate.
Then, in the second episode,
we'll talk about TPU V2 and V3
and learn about how they work
to enable the next generation
of machine learning.
The trouble with
modern computing
is that we keep wanting
more processing power.
Unfortunately, we're beginning
to run into the very limits
of physics.
At least, this is very true
for general purpose processors,
which is what you might
find in your everyday laptop
or smartphone.
The need for more specific
computational power
is what led to the first tensor
processing unit to be created.
Understanding the original
designs of the TPU
and why it was built
that way can help us
as we look forwards
towards designing
machine-learning
architecture and software
systems in the future.
The first tensor processing
unit was built as a PCI Express
expansion card,
and it was plugged
straight into existing server
racks in Google data centers.
It had a 700
megahertz clock speed
and had 40 watts of
power consumption,
and it's been in production
since 2015, powering things
like Search, Translate,
Photos, and of course,
famously featured in the
AlphaGo match in South Korea.
Not only was the TPU
V1 much more performant
than the existing CPUs
and GPUs of the time,
it importantly had a much higher
performance per watt of energy.
These two effects combined
to make the first TPU
a very effective chip.
The chip featured
an architecture that
was specific for deep learning.
It utilized reduced
precision, a matrix processor,
and a minimal design
to reduce overhead.
Let's look at each
of these now in turn.
Neural networks boil down
to a rich set of matrix
multiplications and additions.
The team decided to reduce
the precision of the chip,
using just 8-bit
integers rather than
the conventional 32-bit
floating point numbers
and using a technique called
quantization that could convert
or map 32-bit floating point
numbers to 8-bit integers.
So this allowed significantly
more integer multiplier units
to be fit into a single chip.
So, speaking of
which, let's talk
about that matrix processor.
Conventional processing
systems read and write
to memory very often, sometimes
after every single operation.
This is because they do
general purpose processing.
So in order to support many
different kinds of operations,
the hardware design must
necessarily be fairly generic.
However, this leads
to bottlenecks
due to all of those memory
accesses back and forth.
So what if we could build a
special purpose processor that
performed a much more
limited set of operations,
but did so more quickly?
This is what the TPU tries to
do with its matrix processor.
It uses what's called a
systolic array in order
to do a large hard-wired matrix
calculation without memory
access.
One analogy I've
seen used to describe
this is that a CPU
is like printing out
letters one by one,
stamping them out,
whereas a GPU is printing
out a whole line at a time,
while a TPU, it's stamping
out entire pages at a time.
The core of the TPU is
a huge systolic array,
performing up to 250,000
operations per clock cycle.
Most of the chip is dedicated
to this matrix multiplication
followed by addition operations.
Even though the clock speed is a
seemingly paltry 700 megahertz,
it is performing a ton of
operations every clock cycle.
And one final note
about all of this
is that it is important
to remember that in order
to achieve this design,
the TPU version one only
did predictions.
Now, you can't get your
hands on the TPU V1
or even use it
directly, but every time
you use something like Google
Photos or Google Translate,
there's probably a TPU
powering your search somewhere.
On the next episode
of "AI Adventures,"
we'll talk about the TPU
V2 and V3 and how they work
and how to get your
code to run on a TPU.
Don't miss it.
Thanks for watching this episode
of "Cloud AI Adventures."
And if you enjoyed it, be
sure to click the button
and subscribe to get all
the latest episodes right
when they come out.
If you're hungry for
more TPU V1 action,
you can read the paper that the
team published about the TPU.
I have linked to it in the
description down below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]